[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum boom boom boom
boom ryan good day sir good day to you
you notice anything different in the
podcast room you know
it's a little uh creepier hmm
that wasn't the word i was looking for
well you could almost it's all horror
posters now yeah well i took out the
hockey jerseys and i just said you know
i interview a lot of actors and
producers and things like that i love
entertainment i love horror so yeah i
just started i put all these posters in
in here and uh i really like it you
can't really see but i even have my
urban legend poster up there it's
just the one poster of me uh where it's
my chubby face in the bottom corner
right next to jared leto and terry uh
you know i like it it's just different i
like change but i don't like change yeah
i like the same thing i like eating the
same thing i like
doing the same things i don't like
people taking me out and i'm and i'm
working on that
because i think that's important to get
out of your comfort zone do you do that
uh no not a ton no um
no i agree no i don't change is hard
change is hard and change is gonna come
change is difficult
well we're approach you know it's just
been such a crazy year for everybody and
i know you didn't get to go
home for thanksgiving no and you were
very upset about that
i was because i don't like you change is
hard and i don't i never miss
thanksgiving and i love being with my
family and it's just nice when we go up
and
it always feels like a like a reset for
me because my parents live like on a
they live on a mountain in sonoma rich
the house is actually very modest i will
say okay
um i'm sorry about that man i just i
know that you love your family and
if it makes you feel better i i haven't
seen my family since my grandfather's
funeral last thanksgiving
i haven't seen my mom in years but um
you know the
the these are the sort of things that
everyone's going through it's not just
you it's like everybody i talk to it's
like you know
people who are you know i don't want to
stay responsible because then the people
that go
then you say they're irresponsible but
no i know people are being safe and all
that stuff
it's just it's eventually this is gonna
go away we say it every week so it will
go away
we will at least we have these thoughts
of a vaccine coming and
home testing and this and that and
before we know it
we'll look back and think god do you
remember that that was so horrible i
swear to god do you remember the 2002
oh [ __ ] man hey guys thanks for
listening uh
great episode last week um
with james rodeo rodriguez and with dule
hill
uh just i i love those guys i always
love when
ryan has a good time editing so you
should watch the episode if you haven't
seen it if you just listen to it but i
really appreciate you guys
subscribing on spotify apple podcast
stitcher
watching and subscribing on youtube it
really truly helps the show
and that's all i'll say about that so
just do it if you're thinking about
doing it you haven't done it
if you're here for today's guest and you
like the show please follow us um
our socials ryan uh inside of you pod on
twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook at youtube.com
inside of you we should probably make
one of those and the little social thing
yeah can you just put them oh there they
are right there yeah oh look at that
thanks ryan they're right here you can
just call me bryce there's bryce mixture
bryce does that oh thank you thank you
bryce look at this
yeah see there is it right there i don't
know i want to thank all the patrons
my patrons if you go to patreon.com
inside of you
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside you
could join
the wonderful family and i hope you guys
had a wonderful thanksgiving
um patrons are are uh listeners
friends fans who um want to support the
podcast in another way and they get
special things like
i don't know it's just a tight community
talked about it uh ad nauseam
uh but it's wonderful you know they get
to ask you know [ __ ] talking questions
to the guests some tiers and they get
merch boxes and discounts and
youtube lives with me and zooms it's
just a lot of stuff there's a lot of
stuff there
and um join if you want to it's a lot of
fun i always send you a little message
right after you join that's me of course
i always hate when people say that's not
is it you who's sending them
yes it's of course it's me i could i am
i would feel incredibly guilty i
couldn't live with myself if i wasn't
the one
messaging you know i have these merch
boxes that i send to the
you know the certain patrons um in the
tier
every uh four months or whatever every
whatever
and i make a little note i i write that
out
a handwritten note with a little inside
of you card um
that's me um i just couldn't imagine
somebody
autographing something for me or signing
something from or writing so i think
that's just
just disrespectful isn't it yeah it's
rude it is rude it is
i don't i don't particularly like that
um i also announced uh the name of our
band rob danson and i we have a
new band and it's called sun spin
i know some of you are going sunspin i i
actually really like in fact ryan what
did you say about it
oh i i thought about it some more and
you it's something you can see like on
the back of like a t-shirt for like a
music festival
right yeah you see like fish and sun
spin
radiohead fish sunspin they might be
giants
it just it's simple it's california the
sun
spin uh you know records music
uh it just sort of fits especially the
music that rob and i
are are making and the album's coming
out soon it's called sunspin
um we do stage stages at the end of
every month
the last saturday of every month two
shows pacific time two and six p.m
so uh go to stageit.com type in michael
rosemont follow me on there
and uh you'll get alerts we're gonna
have a bunch of other stuff and
sites and fan all that stuff so we're
really excited about it and um
i think you're going to love the album
which we hope is going to come out in
january or february um we're finishing
it now
and it's just remarkable i'm i'm so
proud of it
and our i'll give a shout out to zach
darling our producer engineer who's
really rocking and everybody who's
worked on the album
um and uh yeah also if you want to go to
the inside of you store lastly
inside of your store um there's tons of
stuff and and take 15
off the code is inside 15.
uh mugs autograph mugs tumblers
autograph tumbler shirts wine glasses
towels bunch of stuff so check it out if
you want
inside 15. uh i love delay and
james and they talk they have a very
special story last week about
their good friend who worked on psych
with them timothy elminson and that was
really heartfelt
and then getting timothy on the show
when he was a little reluctant you know
i don't think he does a lot
and he's been through a lot and you know
we got him on the podcast
and i i don't i don't know what it is
man some people
i just feel like uh i want to hang out
with them i've said it before but
innately just a wonderful human being
and tell some amazing stories and talk
about adversity
having a stroke unexpectedly and
what that does to your family what that
does to your life and your career and
how you navigate and um so that's
amazing but before we get into timothy
elmonson
we have a very special guest she and i
did zoe duncan jack and jane
tv show she's been in hellboy
and cruel intentions and she's done
so many things and she's wonderful and
she's what happens i saw
timothy on larry king and
larry said who is uh your
who do you admire i think it was and
timothy said
selma blair selma uh has ms
and she's stronger than most people i
know
and she's been dealing with that and she
doesn't do a lot of interviews but
i thought that was amazing i had to
reach out to selma and she was so
touched by it
and i said you know what would you get
on here and do a little intro
and she said sure so first before we get
inside of timothy omonson let's get
inside
of selma blair
hi cutie hi lovey how are you
you look good look at your hair i love
your hair
thank you you know i went to chris
mcmillan yesterday and it always helps
you know when you get a good haircut it
makes such a difference i looked like
80s mom you know like yesterday and now
i look like 80s
you know you look younger than an
aunt or a mom thank you even though you
have a uh
a nine-year-old he's nine now yeah he's
nine michael i can't believe that one's
a kid gonna happen for you
you got all serious and looked at me
i don't even know are we on right now
yeah we just we just record
we just recorded we're just yeah we're
cool yeah that's all cool but i'm really
um
i i don't i won't do this to you while
we're actually having our conversation
on a computer but anyhow
michael um i love you and i i mean kids
are overrated it's like a house guest
but like you guys bad manners and stuff
it's really stressful
[Laughter]
you know it's got to be look first of
all i've known you for
since i mean i've known you since i've
known you the longest i mean we did our
first show
rose oh my god we did our first show
educating matt waters
with montel williams yeah was it 1990
who's in new york you've been like a
huge part of my life and i remember your
apartment too
in alphabet city and with matt
and the guy that died in the end of the
hallway and how bad it smelled all
summer
it felt so bad it was so hot
and it was so bad and i'd come over and
like gamble for like off track betting
do you remember that yeah i had an otb
account i forgot that i had an otb and i
would accept people's bets
and i had so much fun and like my
boyfriend at the time like jason
grossfeld came over once and
he's like a huge real like real estate
guy in la
you know in l.a now but huge huge
but uh he did off track betting with us
that was fun
i forgot so a guy just brief so you know
no i know this is a
you know a an intro of selma but i died
in my apartment
and as we were walking in matt and i huh
the guy died in your apartment building
down the hall
and hadn't been discovered for a week
and i said oh my god what is that smell
and that goes
somebody died i go no it's like sour
milk the sourest of all sours
once you smell a dead body you've never
seen a little sandwich
to me it's like a [ __ ] sandwich like a
fecal
sandwich and my sister was a cop
in detroit years ago and she got she'd
find a lot of
suicides or deaths and like it's
it's so fascinating to me i love this
stuff you know like if i die
and i'm not found for a week like i
could be like look like 500 pounds and
might be hissing with
body fluids and gases escape it
okay this is this is morbid i wonder why
i don't sleep well
yeah so that happened and i it smelled
so bad there was that was the summer of
incense
oh drag bedding
listen there's like i i promised you
this wouldn't be long
and you know this is an intro so look
the whole reason we're here is i've
known you forever
and uh you know timothy olmenson who's
the guest on the show today
he um he was on lyric king incredible
incredible actor and he had a stroke a
couple years ago and he's been so brave
and talking about it and like
it really helps people out there and i
know that
all of a sudden i'm watching this
interview and he says um larry king says
so who is you
who is your inspiration who inspires you
and the first thing he says is
selma blair and that's so huge
me you know it's the best um
it's the best feeling someone that you
admire their work the way they live
their life
and then they they mention your name in
any way it never
it's so flattering and this has been
huge to have to learn something so new
you know it
this um stage in the game you know
and it's and he to know about him and
like
is such a great recovery he's made and
that
that's what i'm learning too i just
started
really doing really intense physical
therapy it's hard on zoom
to do pt for brain damage but
um but i but i do it and in speech
therapy and it helps
immensely so when i listen to him and
like saying he's really recovering and
it took
two years really for him to get back to
work
it um made me feel so much better
because i just thought i was going
so slow yeah with going in and out but
but as my neurologist also says brain
recovery is
it's it's such a discipline and it takes
a long time and to see someone put in
the work
and do it and talk so elegantly like he
does about it it's
i'm i'm really happy well you know
what's amazing is
i assumed he knew you why else would you
say some
no but then i thought oh my god maybe
i'm more memory lost than i think i'm
like rosie did i
did i work with him i don't know he did
xena the warrior princess but and i did
a spin-off but we didn't work
together i was cyan the warrior princess
for a minute but um
it didn't it didn't work out so i really
don't
think i did but you know i don't think
you did it
you didn't i asked him for anything no i
think that you honestly
just inspired him by coming out and that
had to be hard look i
i want to just quickly i think it's so
important because you and i share
something that i think
and maybe i think we're both two people
that have always wanted attention wanted
the the life of the party it's like oh
selma's gonna do something or up here
goes rosenbaum he's a
we've got to do something to fit in at
least i've always felt like i had to fit
in
so and i know you talked about i think i
talked to you about this and you think
like a stress had a lot to do and we've
always like
if it's one person i could relate to in
terms of who relates to stress
for some reason i just i'm always
stressing about the little things also
in my bodies and i'm like why are you
worried about the
contractor coming over this morning and
do you still because i know you've been
like really working on that and it's
still
stress the thing like the things that we
thought were little things they'll still
you still activate yes i still stress
and i'm working on it to help but
let me ask you do you think stress
has anything to do with bringing out ms
do you think it has a huge part of what
i
i absolutely do i mean i
i i do um i think stress the mind body
connection is
i really hope that people stop
saying you know like there's just brain
like oh you just have a brain hit no
it's
it's because i go in and out you notice
um
of speech patterns being imperfect
and and and some movement and
um i forget what i'm gonna say wait
there's
the point is that
that this will be the like one of the
biggest um
what were you saying again like look at
this stress like the stress
by the way you're you're saying like a
part of me figuring out how to get
through it when i
my brain just kind of you take your time
and you just do it
and by the way so it's stress and like
so
how do you deal with it i think you know
i was born stressed
it's just like my thing i i maybe came
from like a histrionic family kind of
dramatic
some parts of it and you know i would
kind of adapt into that
i don't know if i wanted to fit in i
didn't
ever think i was worth anything so my
only way
to fit in with people and have friends
was to
make myself the big joke or
or not think nicely i remember not being
as kind growing up i should have taken
some improv classes so it would be yes
and i was always no but you know and
and turned it into this whole like
routine i'd do
because i felt if i did show up
somewhere
i'd have to i didn't think of it as
attention stealing i thought oh i have
to give something
and then it was kind of thoughtless
because you're just then like by the way
i'm cutting you off only because i'm
like like on the verge of tears right
now because i think i'm like looking at
myself like
what you're saying these things are just
like honestly like i found myself being
emotional because i
feel that way i feel like i've always
just tried to like i just don't feel
comfortable i
never felt comfortable so i think you
know we
probably hurt ourselves the stress
probably gets becomes overwhelming
absolutely i mean our central nervous
systems can only take so much ms and
you know i also have you know something
called pots that came about from the ms
it's like a postural orthostatic thing
that
all of us have when we stand up without
you know you pass out but i like will
pass out at anything my heart
changes rhythms um
and it's just i see daily how any stress
how this is not stressful to talk to you
this is amazing to talk to you but just
me
cause i i can't see the screen that well
because
i get double vision up at this thing so
i shut my eyes
and i realized that stress that is a
form of stress
so inner just looking at the screen you
know i'm not upset i'm not crying but
that's stress from my body
for you going out and and
having you know people expect you're
funny michael you know and
and so it's really everything we put
this stress on ourselves
to accommodate and try and be healthy
and then
try and get to sleep and i'm instant
gratification yesterday so
you know like i'll self-medicate with
meditation or negative things in the
past you know
that would you know do all that and it
is all stress and then the way i'd react
to stress or you
that can be more stressful and i
absolutely think i just kind of burnt
myself out
like sure i probably have you know i'm
irish and that's like
people from that hemisphere get get that
nervous system thing more but
all these nervous system things which is
stuff that you deal with too
um we have a lot in the world even
before it got this is more chaotic than
we ever thought
than i ever really allowed myself to
think you know
what it is when people really have to
stop and and realize what's going on and
and the chaos and all that stress even
though my life is very privileged in my
house but i'm stressed for everyone and
i find
yeah you're pretty damn articulate i got
to tell you like your mind like
the way you were sounding like you know
my mind doesn't connect but like the way
you're speaking it's so much more
eloquent that i could ever speak
it really is it really quickly and i
will learn to talk better a lot of it is
just getting these
kind of contractions and then not
breathing correctly there's
calming down does that have not like
calming yourself down i mean
i'm really calm now like i still am like
hyper and i move too fast but i realize
and another thing from watching timothy
is he moves
very purposefully and
he takes his time when he talks
and when i do that
my voice is clearer
as well and it changes your whole
energy and this will take a lot of
therapy
for me to learn to go against my nature
of
rushing to please or rushing to check
out
you know one or the other so it's all
stressful
life for me is stressful like until now
at least when i did get a diagnosis so
much of what we want
is validation just validation to say
someone here is i don't want to hand out
sick or not i mean i love a handout who
am i kidding but
i don't i'm not like
it just feels better to connect with
people and we've connected really deeply
me and you and you've affected a lot of
my friends and
like work i just find more people try
truly try it's just easy and less
stressful to talk to them
because you feel they're not so
judgmental that's less stress it's
all the stuff i think people might be
thinking
and and um and things are worse if i go
out in public i
move worse and at first and i'm like oh
my god is this psychogenic it's all in
my head blair you're crazy you're going
in and out
and it really is to be explained just
the stimulus like light
get the traffic jam or people coming at
me or talking
because i don't have good proprioception
but i can learn
how to train this and staying out of
stress is the key you're absolutely
right i mean i
absolutely believe all the dis-eases i
will give myself in this lifetime have
been an accumulation of like
grief and how badly i might have dealt
with it in the past
but do you do you think oh like this
look i'm gonna let you go now
what what's the one thing or maybe
there's two that you would just say
that really helps with your stress and
just calming you down
ultimately the first thing that comes to
your mind
this too shall pass i mean it's real
it's on my shirt i actually ordered it
i love it um gums at yavor with hebrew i
actually ordered it on amazon um
it's funny enough and i really love it
but it just means this too shall pass
and my mom always said it people in a.a
say it you know
christian i mean it's and in the good
and the bad so
if i'm feeling great i remember this to
shall pass
so enjoy it spend time with your son
make sure you
get on a zoom with michael for this you
know like
but that's it like i just make sure i do
the few small commitments and i keep it
small for now and and then i settle
and it's amazing because it really is
how
everyone is whether you don't have to
have that mess to notice the difference
it's just more extreme because i get
more traffic in the brain but
this is how we are we're made like this
i'm sure so many people who listen to
you
i mean everyone is if you open up and it
is the getting settled
and that's what's happening in our world
right now um hopefully settled in a you
know in
in such a shift happening but um
dude listen i love you so much and i
just you inspire me you you not only
inspire
timothy ellenson but you inspire so many
people and your story and it's just
really that's what life's about is
inspiring people and telling your story
and if it helps one person it's help
that's
that's enough i agree it really it
really is
it's the biggest pleasure of my life
right now
to see my son grow up okay
and to think that
anything that i could do you could do
people i know that anything we could do
would help people in the world because i
think i
felt useless for a long time i never had
a big career path because i was so
thrilled that anyone would give me a job
i would just
kind of take stuff and and and i didn't
ever think i was worth thinking i would
have a career
almost and you know just that thinking
burns you out and i'm a whole
you know different kind of thought
pattern now i don't
i don't i would know i can take care of
myself now before i burn out but
um so much for a five minute
conversation i can't help but we both
love each other we love to talk you're
great on your show and i hate to talk
until i'm talking it's like sex
you watch it until you're in it i mean
if you're an older woman
oh i listen i love you i don't want you
to keep going on because i could talk to
you forever but
i i'm gonna bother you you look
fantastic i love that you're just i mean
you're doing so well and you're you are
an inspiration
thank you so much i love you i really
love you thank you
inside of you is brought to you by
farragun i have you know before they
were a sponsor
i had this amazing thera gun they sent
me but i have i had all their thera guns
i always spent money to get there guns
their gun was like
this is like the original you know this
is not this is the original the but i
i had the i have the first one the
second one i always use these things
somebody who has a lot of
muscle aches soreness injuries
there's nothing like having one of these
suckers
at your disposal uh it's just a fact i
love talking about things that i know
i know about pain i know about tightness
i know about stress and
i don't know what i would do without a
thera gun
and um you know i know you stress
it weighs on all of us right whether
you're elite athletes or just a regular
guy
trying to get through your day like ryan
here muscle pain
muscle tension they're real things and
this is why i use theragun
the handheld percussive therapy device
that releases your deepest muscle
tension using a scientifically
calibrated combination of depth
speed and power and now as quiet as an
electric toothbrush
i love that i could change the speed on
this one it's really cool
the all-new gen 4 theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that's
so quiet you will wonder if it's on
while you soothe your aching muscles
with theragun's signature power
amplitude and effectiveness i travel
with it
i don't go anywhere without this device
right here it is a beautiful thing there
i am
massaging myself oh yeah see how see how
great
look you can tell how happy i am as i
use this and there's
there's ryan ryan how'd you feel because
afterwards you were like dude
that feels so good yes it feels so good
it does it really does i just it it
significantly
helped me significantly reduce my stress
and muscle tension and all that
stuff try theragun for 30 days there's
no substitute for a theragun gen4 with
an oled
screen personalized theragun app and the
quiet and power
you need starting at only 199
199 go to
theragun.com inside
right now and get your gen 4 theragun
today
that's farragun.com inside
theragun.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by geico
we love our guy co ryan we know rents
i do rent right he does and you know
it's not easy
whether you rent whether you buy it's
nothing's easy the number one thing
people are always you know talking about
is i gotta pay my mortgage
correct i gotta pay my rent that's the
most important thing
in fact when you go out to la they're
like uh you know you should make what
you
what your rent is in one week i'm like
what that's not easy for
most people but you know what is easy
is bundling policies with geico geico
makes it easy to bundle your homeowners
or renters
insurance along with your auto policy
it's a good thing too because
you already have so much to do around
your home just go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save
it's geico easy visit geico.com
today that's geico.com
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
how's it going bud i'm i'm doing all
right man thanks for uh spending your
sunday with me you're like
i got to do this podcast for guys
it took me a while to get here no i look
i appreciate you and you know i think
the reason i i wanted you on the show so
much is because
you know i i think you said we met once
a long time ago
i think we we passed somewhere along the
ways in the sutton
place probably we all passed through
it's like the ghost of the seventh place
but then we met you and i actually met
and chatted at uh to troubadour
oh yeah that was uh when we played after
richard spade's band or before that we
opened for them right
yes i think that's what it was that was
a blast but the way
everyone i talked to talks about you
like
i mean i hear this stuff about henry
winkler like he is the
the mensch of hollywood the the was he i
didn't know that yeah like the nicest
guy
you'll ever meet and it's true i worked
with him and he's he's still that guy
who checks and goes michael i'm checking
in
i hope your dog's well irv i hope
everything's great
they can hear it when he texts you can
hear it and um with you it's
sort of that you know i get this feeling
that everybody loves you the best guy to
work with and super talented but you
know
and you went through this whole thing
and there was so much love you forgot
handsome
well definitely handsome wildly handsome
wildly handsome and you have uh
you have style i like the glasses i like
the hat you always
look astute i will say that not only
the dulay and james talk about you but
everybody i've talked to
and i have this thing called patreon
right so
people join patreon the extra support of
the podcast and this and that
and when i just go hey guys who do you
guys want on the show
do you know how many times timothy
omonson came up
oh yeah dude you've got like a fan base
it's not just the psychos
the psychos are the the the fans the die
hard fans from psych
exactly right i just wanted to make sure
now by the way i listen to the um
the one the cast with um jensen apples
yesterday
how's the um what's going to let the
skin catch her oh you got to bring up
the skin cancer
geez well you know the reason i brought
it up was
you know i'm glad you did i was going to
tell you that's right well thanks you
know i
again i brought it up because if there's
anybody out there who just is like you
know i have like my dad won't check
anything
most people don't check anything and the
thing is it's so easy to check something
this was growing and i was like it's on
my thigh
and then my friend carries like why
don't you just go in and just let him
look at it
so he said yeah it's probably nothing
then they called me back and said
yeah it's getting cancer but you know
we're not worried about it we're gonna
go in deeper we're gonna
you know so my the whole point i didn't
wanna like
and i even said it i think on the show
like hey i don't want you don't have to
text tweet me and and all these things i
just want you to know that
just check yourself out now but thank
you
for inquiring or asking about that so
but i also i thought it was really good
that you brought it up
because people do need to check that
[ __ ] yeah i mean with you
i mean honestly before you had the
stroke your health was pretty damn good
right
that's the crazy thing i was in the best
shape of my life that's what james said
he said
this guy worked out religiously lifting
weights i mean you looked at him you
think he's indestructible
that was actually the problem is i felt
between you and me i am i was working at
a crossfit and did
a super heavy deadlift like personal
personal they were going personal best
heavy so you're doing a deadlift i was
doing a deadlift
and um at one point saw stars so what
actually happened
was i i tore a crowded arm or the right
side of my neck
which then led to
eventually it threw a blood clot and hit
the right side of my brain and
took out the left side of my body well
this this freaks me out because i'm a
hypochondriac at times and like
the thought of like going you know you
want to go a little more weight you want
to put some muscle on your body and it's
just like
you're pushing too hard you didn't i
mean were you going harder than you ever
thought you'd
like it would cause any issues no no but
in fact the um
the weight up until i put on more weight
was was fine like i knocked them out
really easily so yeah i can put a put a
little more on then
it just something went wrong and i don't
know what it was and no symptoms by the
way
no no like were there things leading up
to the i know you were like at a film
festival somewhere and
actually the night before i am while in
the screening of the movie
as it was ending i experienced like the
worst pain which headache my life like
a nice pig in the back of my head just
reading and i could not shake it no
matter how much animal i took
so that was the only symptom which i
wouldn't think it's not a stroke
i mean now i i've come to understand
that if you ever say i've had the worst
headache headache in my life you go to
the hospital
doesn't that sort of i mean i know that
when things like i've had a lot of
surgeries and things like that but you
know
if like god forbid i had a heart attack
or a stroke or something like that
isn't it is it always in the back of
your head that you're like
uh i should worry about that i had a
headache is it bad enough to go to the
hospital is it
are you like on top of it are you still
not as uh
crazy about it like for me yeah
headache-wise no like this was this
headache was like one i've never had
before
i was when i was yeah i was in the
middle of something so i couldn't like
go i couldn't just
drop what i was doing to go to the
hospital all right so let's rewind i
don't want to start with that that's
sort of what you kind of might end with
perhaps
but and there's your there's your mug
with your your face on it nothing it's
not vain
it's all right you by the way you have
great facial hair and a nice house by
the way i like the
the roof there where are you right now
where do you live
this is the old little guesthouse in the
back you have a guest house i've always
wanted a guest house
which um unfortunately we can put the
air conditioning on before i can out so
it's
a zillion degrees and we're wearing a
hot straw hat
i'm taking it off so you have good hair
too you see you're actually really hot
right now during this interview
is that what you're telling me you're
incredible at the moment you got me a
little jacked up mike
all right so listen so you you grew up
in missouri in the midwest and i grew up
but i guess
you were born there i was born in
missouri left by the time i was one
group in seattle all right so missouri
throw missouri away you're not a
cardinal fan you're nothing you moved to
seattle you know that's where you have
been have no
knowledge of missouri whatsoever right
and so you
well your parents always like by the way
you know i always talk i always ask this
question but we were parents pretty
supportive growing up where they always
like whatever you want to do
loving i love you that kind of stuff no
i was like very very lucky and
coming from very supportive family and
loving and
it was great and like they were both
kind of into the arts
so took me to the theater took me to the
symphony
then once i said i want to be an actor
they were great really
great because my dad i said i told him
at denny's once i said i'm going to be
an actress i'll eat your steak
i remember it i remember it was after a
play in college he's like come on
you know you're going to college here
you're going to be an actor because if
you think about if you're a father what
are the odds of my son's going to make
it
he's not most likely he's not if you are
betting on this
you bet against your son i mean that
doesn't sound right by the way if you're
going to go for a steak go to denny's
exactly that was uh you know he took us
to denny's but you know i didn't mind
denny's
but you know to have your parents
support i always say you could always
tell when you meet someone
if they had a good upbringing most the
time like i could just there's just
i've seen some interviews with you i've
there's just this
genuine gentle soul that's just a good
heart
people talk about you so you know
overwhelmingly and so
when i was i knew you were gonna say i
had a good upbringing before i even knew
anything about you i knew it because i
could just tell by your
disposition of the way you carry
yourself and there's just a certain
confidence there's a certain like
you don't it seems like you don't stress
out about the little things do you
i try not to well what stresses you out
you know were your parents they never
fought they never
you know you you had no dysfunction you
were just you didn't deal with a lot of
uh adversity growing up you think
no i mean i really didn't there was
underlying grumblings behind the doors
but nothing there was there were no
place being thrown
i could tell you some stories
oh yeah i grew up in a small my whole
family was from new york but we
we moved from like we lived in
connecticut for two years and then we
moved to indiana my dad was like
i mean he was 19 when i was born and
then he was 25 when my brother was born
he already adopted
my two my brother and sister for my
mom's first marriage so
look you know it's a it was a [ __ ] show
but you know
but having parents that are taking you
to the theater and doing all these
things and there's love and
they were open they're like i love you
timothy timmy i love you so much you
always felt that right
yeah in fact my dad always made a point
of saying it which was um
every day he said it not every day but
he i mean he just wanted to make sure
that
i know i was loved poof that is so
important people don't realize how
important it is to just tell your kid
i love you and in the mind even if
they're a [ __ ] up or you're you're
worried about you know they're not doing
exactly what you thought they'd be doing
just to give them that like hey i love
you no matter what that is a huge thing
for someone to hear especially
you know growing up right absolutely i
mean it was a little when you're 12
years old your dad's saying that she's
like hey just you know i love you you're
like what the [ __ ] man
okay great thanks dad did you say what
the [ __ ] no of course not
i swear my father would have he would
have what i
would he would have been rather across
with me oh he wouldn't have loved him
i would have gotten the eyebrow and um i
can't imagine never swearing in front of
my parents
what's the elements in eyebrow it was
the um the right i
i can't do any more extensive stroke but
pretty classic the eyebrow rays
really storage fiber oh so since the
stroke you can't do that
because i can't look i don't look at you
and think there's anything wrong like
anything wrong or not working on you but
you know
what are the things that aren't working
uh like if my if i'm sitting next to my
dog my dog licks my my left ear i can't
feel it
or licks the side of my face but i know
the um
yeah the eyebrow doesn't work anymore
now it's just like both go up where
the eyebrow before was sort of a
trademark in my work i was able to
convey a lot of emotion with
an arched eye bro do you try do you is
are there exercises are there things
that they're saying they this could come
around
this could come around uh yeah i mean
actually i haven't really talked about
that part it's more of the um vocally
i'm not what i used to be
what do you mean like i had that used to
have this sort of really rich
deep baritone voice which is not kind of
really throaty and just like when
we were texting about being articulate
right i didn't mean like intellectually
articulate i mean like i get a little
mush-mouthed
i tend to speak too fast now and just
run
right on so i really do have to work on
slowing down my rate of speech because
everything gets a little grumbled
so you purposely do that you purposely
slow down the way you talk just because
you want to make sure you're articulate
enough or whatever
actually i don't do it enough it's not
something that's right in my that i
think about enough
i think my text back to you is like just
hang out with me for half an hour and
you'll feel
so articulate it was something like that
yeah you will feel
incredibly articulate um it's funny you
brought up my skin cancer thing earlier
because
i'm wearing a hat i wear a hat anyway it
doesn't matter i don't care but i went
in there to get a body check before they
take the thing
you know they ripped the rest of it out
of me and uh he goes oh let me take that
thing off your nose
like what he's like it's pre-cancer no
big deal i'm like jesus
christ so you
yeah i mean you know it's like he's like
look you're going to live your life
normally you're not going to worry about
these things you're going to go about
your business and
this is what it is and that's kind of a
really good message in a lot of ways
look
if he thought you know he's obviously be
smart wear spf and these things like
this
by the way i know we're kind of going
back and forth but do your doctor say
these are certain things i don't want
you to eat these are certain things i
don't want you to do
there's got to be a list of things that
you they kind of tell you right
sure what are those things uh
with me was like you know don't smoke
and um
i mean obviously it's just the stroke
it's that not that i really smoked but
um
and then you know watching my
cholesterol is one for me i mean i'm 51
now
so the basically so again we're going
back to working out and we're working
out
we're talking about the pre-stroke so
i'd lost a bunch of weight
i'd always been sort of a little skinny
fat you got a little bell i was trying
to lose
so i was doing super high hardcore
cardio lost a bunch of weight and that's
when i wanted to put on some weight
i just wanted to put on some muscle thus
the weight left hand
and that can be very dangerous obviously
which i just found out the hard way
right so you weren't getting help
necessarily to do all these things to
build you know
body mass or whatever but you were doing
it on your own but reading about it and
things like that correct no i mean i was
i was going across that
so i was doing lifting there which and i
had done crossfit for years
and um eventually got more like i don't
need to lift these weights anymore
and then because i got so skinny and i
wanted to put some weight on it i would
say so my vanity almost killed me
welcome to [ __ ] hollywood being an
actor [ __ ] you know it's so funny too
because i don't think people people
always
talk about overweight and how they're
trying to lose weight and
i've always been really real real thin
in fact i always got picked on or
talking about you're
skinny or you know i didn't look at
these guns yeah well you know
but i i was always kidding but i it's
just as hard because i always want to
gain weight i got to lift muscles
because you know i have
friends like you look too skinny rosin
bomb you got to gain some weight
and i'm like [ __ ] you know so i'll get
the gym and you know it's hard it's hard
to gain weight it's hard to maintain
weight just as it is hard to lose weight
and stay you know and i think for actors
it's like we've people
don't realize everyone talks about sort
of
girls and their issues but for for men
like
what the checkouts are there's men's
fitness there
just as much as there's all the the
magazines that maybe women are more
looking at yeah
we're seeing you know hugh jackman all
jacked up and you jackman all jacked up
that's one of those tongue twisters you
say before you do a play after a stroke
that's hard too
did do you do those because i know in
theater we do those rubber baby buggy
bumpers he thrusts his fists against the
post and still
the rest of the yeah those are so hard
now but do you
does it help you when you keep doing
that to for speech and things and
articulation
yeah i think it does even sort of like
trying to do some well
just like vocal range warm-ups before
i'm talking for a long time
yeah but then did i do them today no i
didn't you didn't
score so i can't [ __ ] about being old
mushroom i think you sound fine
you know what i was gonna go start kind
of like from the beginning in a way and
work but i'm like you know what [ __ ] it
this is like this is kind of all
together because i guess the big
picture is you're a great actor you're
incredibly funny you've had a lot of
success
and you know there's so many ideas and
things that i have and i usually think
about you know it's it's
a lot of guests think it's therapy for
me and it is but it's therapy for
everybody else and it's like how do you
how do you look you have two you know
beautiful daughters and you have a wife
and you're a good loyal guy and you know
there's probably no
moment in your mind where you're like oh
my god [ __ ] this i don't want to be
alive you've ne you never thought that i
guarantee you
not for me no i would mental health why
she's talking yeah
i know i've been very fortunate in that
regards where that's not something i've
ever really struggled with
that that's that's such a that's a gift
that really is a gift it's like you know
uh because i know a lot of people
probably including myself you know when
something happens
there's something about it even when
i've had these big surgeries and i'm
eight months out and i'm in horrible
pain and popped up on pills
do you say popped up on pills or pumped
up on pills i always thought it was
hopped up
well whatever this is why you're the
articulate one here
hopped up on pills and you're like i
just you almost it's almost it comes a
point in your life where you're like i'm
young i'm indestructible i
i could do anything and boom reality
hits you in like surgery
this that and you're like wow i'm
the um i mean one of the things with
post-stroke that's been a big sort of
topic around
my life and people who know me as and
people who don't know me
asking you like how do you maintain this
attitude
because i kind of made the decision
really early on that a pity party wasn't
gonna help me
i had there was this uh there was a
counselor at the clinic i was
i would i go to a neural rehab clinic
every day
and the early stages of my rehab there
was a counselor i would see
and i sat down one day and she was like
how are you i'm like i'm great she goes
yeah that's everybody says
everybody all the therapists say you're
great what's going on how do you do it
and we talked for i was like i don't
know i think the big point was like i
was saying my parents were depression
era
like you don't [ __ ] in wine wow
being in the icu in a kind of
slowly starting to think syncing up what
happened to me because
like right off the stroke like i
couldn't walk was in a wheelchair it
could
i mean i'm not able to walk with it with
a cage shorter distances
now and now you walk with a cane shorter
so i really had a rehab to learn how to
walk
i still wear leg brace because the um
the muscles around my
my my left ankle aren't can't support me
so
if i were wearing the brace would just
buck when i would go down
and my left arm st my left hand and arm
hand doesn't work
so i'm doing therapies for that and
that's slow but it's a little bit better
than it was
like before there used to be absolutely
nothing on my arm but now i've got a
little short moment
all right so i'm making slow progress
but anyway so as it was sort of
hitting me what the hell was going on i
literally said to myself
wait a second you became a successful
actor you beat hollywood
the stroke's nothing like recovering
from a stroke like i can do this what a
way see
to put things in perspective like that i
mean was it like that from the get-go
you wait
take me back to the point where you wake
up in the emergency room or in the
hospital
and your wife's there is she with the
kids and like
what is what's going through your mind
and what's going through her mind and
what so i
when i when the stroke first hit me i
was in bathroom in the temp airport and
i collapsed my left
leg my left leg went out front of me i
collapsed got up collapsed again
i guess someone got me out into the
waiting area where there were
some paramedics came and tended to me
and they're
a bunch of people shouting at me and um
you know they're doing the the stroke
checklist of shows your teeth tell us
your name what year is it
who's the president and i literally i
was still with enough to think
i mean my normal joke could have been
haven't i suffered enough
but i i was with enough to think wait a
second you're in florida these are first
responders
these are probably trump people don't
crack wise you need these guys on your
side
don't be an [ __ ] right now right
right so i was thinking that clearly
enough to do that
and then i remember being in this
putting out a gurney and i'm
in the back of the ambulance my legs are
kind of up like this you know
and um i remember looking at the um the
texture of my jeans
just i just noticed the weave of the
fabric and it kind of hit me like
this is not good you got you got a wife
because you gotta get
this is not [ __ ] good everybody
actually
as i was waiting for the parameters to
come in or whoever was going to come
take care of me
i was sitting in the uh sitting in the
waiting area i kept falling off the
stool because i was trying to lean on
this side am i
not realizing my left arm wasn't working
so i
i think as it seemed to think not
knowing what the hell was going on just
all inside just i kept falling down
i'd stand up and fall down and people
gather on me and yelling
i remember [ __ ] going [ __ ] something's
not right oh [ __ ] i never did that
in case you merged anything on your
phone you know you're supposed to ice
so at one point they they're talking to
me and i told them to call my wife and i
gave them my wife's phone number and i
said
um eventually they're like okay we got
we got your wife on the phone like yeah
don't freak out okay they're like that's
not gonna happen
but for my wife's side of stories cut to
them screaming in at her on the phone
your wife's had us your husband's had a
stroke get to template immediately
so the worst [ __ ] moment of this
problem is life oh my god
it's like seven o'clock in the morning
so then she makes some emergency phone
calls to her best friend and some other
dear friends
who sweep in and swoop in and grab our
kids and take care of them
and then it was only like months later
me
after i'm home that my oldest daughter
lily
confided to her mom that just she was
just in such
terror for a really long time not
knowing what that was going on just
knowing that i was sick and in a
hospital
so it really i mean for as much as it
affected me
much for much more beyond that it's
affected everyone in our household
oh so it's almost like you know you go
probably through a process and
in a sense i mean this is extreme it's
probably not a good analogy i'm not full
of great analogies but if someone passes
away
you go through all these stages right
you go through or any kind of loss you
go through
you know the grief the anger the all
these things there's probably
in a sense like this happened to dad
we're going through this it's the trauma
of it all and then real you know dealing
with it all these stages that they have
to go through as well
i assume absolutely in fact i think it
affected my daughter nora probably more
than affected lily
she's just a little more sensitive so i
think she absorbed it a little more
so one point we said alice and i sat
them down we're all still trying to
grasp what the hell happened
and the thing like with the brain injury
you don't know what you don't know until
you
kind of presents itself like for me
because it was a right side injury it
affects different things it affects the
left side right hemisphere
injury will affect the left side of your
body then there's other
subtle things go with it like attention
like i couldn't look somebody in the air
like it just took me forever like
look at somebody i'd get distracted go
off it really bothered my youngest
daughter that i couldn't that it
didn't look like that when i talked to
her that's something i really had to
work on
once i was made aware of it with through
my cognitive therapist
how long did something like that take it
was um
ongoing for months i would say until
finally i would get a little better and
she would sort of make a note oh dad's
getting better he's living in the i know
that's rude so anyway allison my
beautiful wife and
and i set the girls down like okay look
this happened
obviously and it sucks so we got to
figure out what what
the message is here i said the best i
can sort of do is i think the lesson
here is
bad things happen in life but it's
how you respond to them that define you
so part of my recovery my
drive to get better was always about i
got to get better for these girls
i got to keep working for them and get
back to try and get back to something i
mean
about a week before i had my stroke lily
and i were hiking up and
running canyon well we used to hike i
mean she and i wouldn't hug
i would hike every day but a lot of
times she would come with my dog
it's like i've got to get back to that
canyon spot
just uh in fact in i mean there's a lot
of things i gotta go back to
but one of the overwhelming driving
forces was always my girls and
my family i mean um it's crazy when this
happened
because i was at the zenith of my career
and then professionally said and then
personally alison and i just bought like
the house for our dreams we've been
waiting 10 years to buy
we're literally an escrow when it
happened so i'm in the icu
she flies in with her best friend jensen
thank you jensen and to my best friends
from
from high school and my best friend from
la they all fly to kind of take care of
her
and she's fielding for calls from our
mortgage broker about
are we pulling out of this deal and i
was sort of
the church i learned because i was not
in my quite right mind i was sort of
wake up out of these fever dreams going
keep the house i want the house i kept
drinking there was this pool like i'm
dreaming of rehabbing in that pool
right so wake up she's like we've got to
make a decision like keep the house keep
the house
my financial advisor was in florida he
drove in he's like don't keep the house
uh we thought we had enough money for it
he's
unforeseen medical expenses because
that's all i'm gonna say
you and thank god we thank god we didn't
keep the house because obviously my
career kind of came to a massive halt
you know working a little bit but surely
not the level i was before
so my income is certainly up in question
it's incredible i mean i can't even
imagine
and by the way do you have strokes in
any strokes in the family history
uh my grandmother had one but that was
an old age kind of stroke
right but mine was this weird thing like
you didn't realize that young people
have strokes our friend rob benedict you
know rob bennett attacked him
robbed my dear friend from supernatural
right are you open for his band
yeah i love him he's such a great guy
he's the best so rob had a stroke and
um which they never really came to the
bottom of the wedding but he also had a
carotid artery this section his was on
the left side
which the left side affects your speech
more
so he's actually been really
instrumental in helping me sort of come
to this and
guide him my way of so i would look at
him a lot and see how far he's coming
like he's coming quickly more
inside of you is brought to you by
nutrafall uh well another product that
my friends love uh neutrophil sent me
some products
and uh you know uh talk about
easy to use capsule my friends grabbed
it they're like you don't need this
i'm like hang on but i ended up giving a
a bottle to my friend joe
i gave a friend to my my friend tom and
to one of my girlfriends
tanya so you know it's guys it's girls
80 million
men and women in the u.s experience
thinning hair it's just common
okay and uh it's still not openly talked
about which
can make going through it feels scary
and stressful
and that just adds to the problem you
know i think um
if you could fix it if you could do
something about it
and it's easy neutral fall control isn't
given it's taken
take charge of your hair growth and make
the next few months
your time to grow thicker fuller
healthier
hair in a time when self-care is more
important than ever every day is an
opportunity to skip
damaging styling tools and chemicals and
focus on better hair growth
from within what i love about neutrophil
it's a
physician formulated 100 drug
free did you hear that drug free they
use natural clinically effective
botanicals for better hair growth
through whole body health does it work
yes in clinical studies neutral fall
users saw
thicker stronger hair growth with less
shedding in three to six
months eighty percent saw improved
hair growth and thickness in a
randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled study of neutrophil
for women by a board-certified
dermatologist
whether you're experiencing thinning or
not
you deserve hair as strong as you are
neutral fall can help you achieve your
best
hair growth naturally so you could join
my friends
because people all over are using
neutrophil you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to nutrafall.com
and using the promo code inside to get
20 percent off this is their best offer
available anywhere plus free shipping on
every order
get twenty percent off at nutrafall.com
promo code inside
their best offer anywhere twenty percent
off at nutrafall.com spelled
n n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-com
promo code inside for hair as strong as
you are
inside of you is brought to you by
echelon i love this company
i have their products here at my house
um
to be able to i'm a bit of a hermit and
you know i have uh i have some you know
i have bad back
bad neck things happen in the course of
a life
what's great is i can go downstairs and
use the rower and work on my back i
could
do the mirror and take a boxing class or
a stretching class or a yoga class
it's all there for you with echelon and
you know one of my good friends erica
christensen you might remember her from
parenthood
she's been raving about it she's been
posting about it my friend laura
vandervort she got one she's been raving
about it so
there's no secret you know my trainer
always says you know what the secret is
there's no secret you gotta just do it
you get one and you start feeling better
about yourself
echelon offers the next generation of
connected fitness bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines and
their all new echelon stride
smart treadmill no matter what your
favorite fitness activity
echelon gives you a fun and challenging
workout from the comfort of home
their world-class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand
studio level classes always available
when you need them and unlike their
competitors echelon is affordable
for everyone and one membership lets up
to five family members
all work out at the same time when it
comes to getting or staying in shape
nothing feels as good as the feeling of
accomplishment
of hitting your fitness goals and
feeling great about yourself
right now you can try any echelon
fitness equipment at home
for 30 days yeah just go to
echelonfit.com
inside of you that's e c h e
l o n fit dot com slash
inside of you you know you said
something um
well you're in the ambulance i believe
you said you saw the texture on your
pants
right you saw you just were staring at
it and you were just hyper focused on it
with all this craziness happening you're
saying this is bad
i just remember like when my grandmother
died who was like i just
loved this woman more than it was my
first real terrible loss i remember
you know hearing on the answer machine
and it was like my uh aunt she was like
michael it's
it's denise please uh please call me
back as soon as you can
and i just knew and i remember you know
the cottage cheese ceiling you know that
texture there was one dark dot i think
i've talked about this but
on the ceiling i just remember staring
at it for 15 minutes
and just sort of just just zoned in on
it kind of
taking it was just this hyper-focused
like evaluation of what
how are you going to deal with this
prepare yourself
and everything sort of comes at that
hitchcock soon
exactly and it was like this is what you
have to do and i went from
absolute fear and just devastation to
i've got to call my mother and tell her
that our mother's dead i'm the one who
has to call these
people i have to be the sane one which i
mean look at me
timothy it's not it's not easy to say
that but um
it's just i mean you can sit here you're
obviously incredibly brave and
and you know i just keep thinking you
know such a great actor and you are
and then right after this you know
they're able to for
psych for the they're doing a movie
lassie returns which is
kind of a twist on your character's name
right yeah my character's
called right his nickname was lassie so
they called it
it was called last you come home if
you're gonna be official with the titles
and they had to re-figure the script to
kind of get you
they wanted to get you in there yeah so
especially the we did two movies the
first movie happened
as i was just after while i was
in the really the big throws of my
recovery they were filming the first
movie
so james rode and steve franks our
creator of the show
hold up joey's right across the street
from the sun place hotel in vancouver
which was our kind of our clubhouse they
sat there for three days and rewrote the
entire movie
to get me into a cameo which by the way
we shot right back here
so i shot so they could make so they
want to make sure i could get in the
movie to get
to make my insurance and get paid so
they reduced my roll down to am a
facetime call with maggie lawson
and um again just the love of these guys
showed me to
to get me in the movie and then the
second movie was really all about his
recovery
i'm just thinking so we were back here
shooting in the in the guesthouse
scene and then at the end i'm standing
closer outside here in the
backyard and i asked james to help me
walk to the front of the house and i was
walking with the stick and
it goes hey very much you couldn't walk
at all i was like oh [ __ ] i do that's
right i couldn't walk
so it's little moments like that where
um you know there was just uh
when i was in this clinic every now and
every night every now and then have like
a group a group chat with them
someone would be asked to speak and
there was this guy there who was um
a little older sort of very salt of the
earth
and um yeah i think he was a farmer but
it could have been a longshoreman for
lino but
he was talking about how he hated being
in in the clinic and before the clinic
we were in
i call it a halfway house for strokes
because you're sort of a residential
living facility to kind of learn how to
take care of yourself a little bit in
whatever ways you can
but so they're watching and suddenly you
go from being a very private person
having eyes on you 24 7.
this guy was talking about living in
this fish bowl and how much he hated it
but then he said the best thing that i
ever heard he uh really taken with me
and taking her we said honor the
milestones
so with recovery you have to honor the
milestones to think back like oh that's
right i used to not give a walk
i have a um an album on my photo of my
phone
like my recovery album of just videos of
me when i started learning how to walk
again
just every kind of little milestone of
like trying to get my hand to move
or then i would i spent a lot of time
sort of texting people to voice voice
messaging with people and sending
videos back and forth with friends in
the uk so look back at those and just to
see what my voice was then
what's amazing is you know you're doing
this and the one thing that comes to
mind for me is
shouldn't we be doing that all the time
in life where we're like
hey take this moment man this is a great
moment in your life take this moment
don't
go past just say hey this is an
achievement this is you've accomplished
this this is this is a
and i think we do that i know i i do it
constantly where
it's like being grateful but in your
position it's like
the condition you're in you're like you
could think how can i be grateful
but like every step along the way you
are it's like these achievements and
you're like i am going in the right
direction i am getting better i'm able
to walk
i wasn't walking this is this is oh my
god
you know people take for granted like i
could see things every day
some people can't so i don't know it's
pretty
it's it's pretty powerful stuff it's you
know i try to go to bed every night and
say
what are you grateful for don't think of
all the [ __ ] you haven't done don't
think of all the bad things you're going
to say about yourself and then go into
nightmares because that's the stuff that
gets you into nightmares
why don't you think you know positive
things and so it's just it's just
amazing you know
i will say like your cat the cast i mean
were the with the cast from supernatural
in the cast from psych
um how so
unbelievable did they come when did was
the first time they saw you
i mean when they came and saw you or
well let's see i know
maggie and james and dulay came to visit
me in
my rehab clinic and at lunch with one
time and uh one of my physical
therapists
rebecca and i should see this but
rebecca was he was a huge psych fan and
said that
psych was the show that got her through
med school so it kind of tricked me up
like
here's this woman who's helping helped
me to really learn how to walk
and psych is the show that helped get
her you know get her through that
that really tough part of college to do
that
wow who didn't keep their [ __ ] together
someone had to cry immediately when they
saw you
um no they were all pretty stunning
really none of them
they're like you know because there's
that thing where we gotta be strong we
gotta make them laugh
we gotta do everything i'd be like oh
timothy oh [ __ ] man
[ __ ] i assume they were crying on the
inside but trying to be strong for me
right right right
but um in fact and then while i was
really recovering those guys were all
filming the movie and while they were
filming they would send me
um videos of we had this tradition on
our show
singing after we have to ask maggie
because we never wrong a singing happy
birthday to someone
like if there was a guest star we really
loved our director somebody we really
like
got along with who's sort of like one of
us
and they were wrapped we would sing
happy birthday
but it was more than just happy birthday
it meant we love you
oh and monk who was our a camera
operator who shot
every scene i think we ever did in that
series it was sort of hit the first note
we all had a there was like a band you
know there's a crew band
so he would hit the first note of just
this big old
ha and we all knew it was on and then
this entire crew would sort of
hit the note and 200 people would sing
this amazing
harmony version of happy birthday and
the person we were singing to was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
and then we'd applaud she was just our
way it's just our way of saying hey
you're one of us you're one of us we
love you right and so while
i was recovering and they were shooting
the movie
they came up with team tim and they um
would send me videos of them shooting
vancouver singing happy birthday to me
which
i mean that's the kind of stuff that got
me through all this
friends like that and friends outside of
that show that really
just held me together and kept me
motivated to go
and then while we were shooting well
apparently while i was shooting that
scene with maggie
my my facetime scene back here she was
obviously in vancouver
she said the story the entire crew kind
of got gathered around her
to support her watch you shoot because
it was really emotional scene for her
character me
so she apparently was a mess that day
and our first city
came up and said look behind you and she
saw the whole the whole crew just like
waiting there for her
to represent me just um the most amazing
group of people by the way
the happy birthday song were there any
people that at the end of their shot
shooting that they didn't get a happy
birthday song because no one could stand
them
um there might have been i'm not going
to name names
i had to think he just couldn't say it
would be kind of like if you did it for
everybody that's really kind
but if you're saying you loved working
it means we love you there had to be a
few you're like
i ain't singing this [ __ ] song and i
certainly am not harmonizing for this
[ __ ]
but i'll tell my head i can't remember
exactly which we had so many amazing
guests on that show i can't remember
which ones
right that's amazing like because it was
vancouver
if you came up for the weekend you were
you came into the show you're gonna be
there for the weekend
there was gonna be a dinner there were
gonna be drinks if that if you drink so
we were really social group and social
with our guest cast
right yeah i always thought it was like
one of the best shows to work on
it was just incredible from so many
people it's always like psych you know
the people and
it was just so easy and so fun and you
know james in fact delay though i mean
they said something like they just
wouldn't allow [ __ ] to come on said
there's a total policy they're like yeah
they make a con go hey this guy's not
what
you know this can't happen you can't you
know and actually that that policy i
mean that attitude of
it being a great show which we all took
great pride in it being
a place you want to come and work on
that really came from
james and dulay i don't know which ones
i'm not i don't know who's going to
claim the most
was definitely a massive part of that
let me ask you this how hard is it to be
realistic with too optimistic with
what your doctors are telling because
you hear stories where they'll say oh
you're never going to walk again
and then the guy's running marathons you
hear stories can so you can never really
believe when doctors say
this is as good as it's going to get is
there a big part of you that's like
five years from now i'm going to be able
to do ninety percent of what i used to
be able to eight seventy percent or
eighty
yeah i mean nobody's ever really said
you're never gonna do this again or that
again although at the time
which i didn't realize this i learned
this later they apparently told my wife
that
my neurosurgeon was afraid i was never
gonna walk again i walked into a
restaurant with my um
i was meeting my manager my agent for
dinner
and every time they're like oh [ __ ] look
at you walking down because
restaurants are hard because there's
usually stairs and i have a vision break
on my left side so
anytime you walk into a room it's just
it's overwhelming
so just to be able to walk into a
restaurant that i've never been at
and get to the table and sit down i'm
going geez you look how good you're
walking
then allison told them that i was like
well i think they never told me this
i do remember very specifically being in
the icu and
every day my surgeon juan valdivia hey
juan shout out juan
juan juan valdivia thank you like one of
the
best neurosurgeons in the state was on
call that night and um i got to have
dinner with him a few months ago and he
obviously pre-covered was he blown away
by your recovery it was very
sweet but every day he would come in and
he we talked at the store actually and
he reminded me
the number of the bed i was in and um he
would squeeze my left my left foot to
see if i could feel it
and i could never feel it so one day he
takes me they wheeled me into a
into a room and he shows me my cat scan
and this portion is you know this
portion is all gray and i remember
thinking oh gray matter it really is
great matter
but it was totally shadowed like because
you can see where the stroke was like
there was so much brain damage on that
side
he said so this is where you had your
stroke it was massive
because i got to tell you most people
when i was surviving a stroke like this
which i kind of sat back and i was like
what do i do with that information
it's like [ __ ] now what do i do guess i
gotta come back from this
you know um one thing i don't
i think you said underestimate yeah
handsomeness
style style style talent
talent overwhelming talent um
zag insurance second insurance for now
as long as i can
keep it you will but um or the bravery
thing and
it's really i mean a lot of people have
reached out and saying you know you're
an inspiration and that's really lovely
in fact i've got this
i'm going to show off my my fancy shirt
i just my daughter designed this
broken i love it so we were selling
these to a company called stands to help
raise money for
the stroke association to bring
awareness to stroke survival stroke
prevention and rehab but um
part of the broken thing i just want to
it's not a brand new idea but
you could think about how you can bend a
stick or tree branch to a certain point
until
it breaks and it's kind of like i'm not
broken yet
i'm unbroken and so through this and
meeting other stroke survivors get a lot
of really lovely interaction with people
saying i'm it's inspirational but
i really do want to address the burglary
part of everything out of me going yeah
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm not going
to wallow in i'm not going to sit and
well i'm not going to have a pity party
in the corner
where that's one thing i mean mourning
your physical health or mental health
or emotional health you know a lot of
ways to feel like maybe i haven't really
been dealt with it so i haven't really
delved into what i can't do i try really
trying to focus on what i can do rather
what i can do
but i don't know how brave it is but um
where i haven't really sat in it too
much because i'm almost afraid my wife
had to talk about this a little bit
i'm almost afraid if i do get there if i
do go to that point i'll get really
angry and
maybe won't be able to recover from that
so my i've just been sort of stiff upper
lip
but again i don't know if that's the
healthiest way to go
well i i i've got a little brain
analysis and really delve into it
yeah because it amazes me i you know i
think gosh how many breakdowns would i
have had within the first
you know month like god i love it oh
like yeah
you know just like you know what i i'm
sure
and it's just like you know everyone has
different ways of dealing with it but
you know
it's amazing i think you know what i
gather
you know briefly what we talked about in
the beginning just this upbringing and
this love
and then you think about your family and
suffering
through the depression you've got these
two wonderful girls you've got this wife
and you've been so lucky
somehow in your mind you've been sort of
programmed
inadvertently or whatever that you know
that's why you were able to
put things in perspective like you did
the way you handled is the way that
that's of course how tim is going to
handle it
now i think a big part of it also is i
was always an optimist but i mean
i was always a what's on the other side
of the hill kind of guy i mean i think
he got to be to be an actor
because you come to this town and you're
like i'm going to try to do this thing
that
they'd give you the numbers for like if
you really let listen to the numbers
no one would ever really try this it's
like of course of course nobody's going
to work nobody's going to succeed
so because always been yeah let's give
it a shot let's see what's over there
let's keep going moving forward
and i've always been a um
it could always be worse kind of guy i
mean i
i have a friend with a terminal disease
so it's like what am i going to see her
[ __ ] i'm going gonna cry because i
can't
walk i can't run or hike like he used to
so it's like
you know you really just i have to look
around i've got plenty of friends plenty
of friends with ms who
are having a really difficult time so i
know a lot of people that are in much
worse
situations than me and i think just
having the
perspective of positivity has always
been has helped me kind of
look at things differently now when i'm
in the situation yeah and knowing you're
loved
by the way knowing the overwhelming
amount of love that you you've been
given that's it's massive i think that
has to be such a big part of just like
so many people are rooting for you and
like the fans and the psychos and the
i mean it's just like i could tell in
having that
being loved that much i mean being loved
is important alone but being loved that
much
has got to give you the strength or help
with the strength to get through things
it really does i mean it absolutely does
knowing that there's people out there
who give a [ __ ] of how i'm doing that
day and um
this day said i want to go to the clinic
like i'm tired
i'm [ __ ] this my leg hurts but i think
of my friends who
who are rooting for me and
the people different phantoms out there
who were just so pulling for me and
reaching out in various ways
i was like i got to get up off my ass
you got to go do this
because in a way i i don't want to let
them know i would like my kids so i
don't want to let myself down my wife
down
you know maggie i always had us this
thing on the show
like you know it doesn't matter how
great a job is
i've always tried to think of i don't
have to go to work i get to go to work
yeah that's nice one of my best friends
from from seattle is um
an er nurse like during covet so he's
under incredible stress and we kind of
we're checking quite a bit
and our other our friend mike is um a
very positive man
and darren at the end of a really long
day we'll kind of check and go i helped
i got to help some really vulnerable
patients that were in sick today
it's like really like he just faces
every morning waking up to going
this is what i get to do these are the
people i get to help everyone goes well
thank god you got out of bed that day
so several years ago i can't do time
anymore so i remember when it was
um i really can't no you're smiling i
can't i can't tell you like oh yeah it
was ten years ago
could have been five years ago it could
have been 20. but somewhere during psych
i don't know which season
i was fortunate enough to get to go to
um the middle east to visit troops
so i was in qatar for a week at a
place called camp australia which was
the main r r base for
both iraq and afghanistan so the
soldiers were coming in literally from
the field
for a couple days for like four days of
er or r r
and are you just started i mean i'm not
saving lunch sitting there shoot to
shoot the [ __ ] with these men and women
and tell them they're appreciated and
one day i'm talking this young guy
like hey man how do you like the base
like there's a pool there was a bar
and um there's a nice gym and like how
do you like this
i mean what do you think is this okay he
goes sir they give me three beers a day
and nobody's trying to kill me it's
a-okay and that really just
pierced my heart three beers a day
because then they would give you a
ticket for like you could get three
beers
in the in the bar so i went back to the
set
of psych and told me i get the story
whenever we get a little [ __ ] here
about
our trailers are too far from yeah again
no matter how great a job is there's
always something that pisses you off
like our trailers how far from the set i
gotta walk how far
what and then you'd say are you getting
helen for lunch
so if we get a little snippy she could
look at me or i could look at her and go
hey
maggie three beers okay shut the [ __ ] up
good one
[ __ ] right she's gonna stolen food
she's talking to me
[Laughter]
well look this is this is it's it's
amazing how you put things in
perspective and i know you say that that
you know this is
look i mean that's that's what happens
you you make a decision it's like i
could either crumble or i could you know
but like overall do you really
think i'm gonna be back on my feet and
i'm going to be acting i'm going to be
i'm going to get strong is there a real
a reality to it in terms of like
or do you just say i'm going to get is
i'm going to keep going as hard as i can
to get
i mean what do you want what do you want
to do where do you see yourself five ten
years from now
god that's the million dollar question i
really don't know all i know is i just
need to keep plugging away because i do
see myself getting my walking's getting
faster and stronger
and my wife picks me up to click and
she'll say how was school today we'd
call it school
it's like you'll never know what i did
in school today you'll never believe it
so i can give her these updates the
other day i was able to um
like i was working on this is us and
there's i have a line on that show where
i play a stroke survivor
and uh my line is i'm just trying to
walk one month
my goal right now is to walk one lousy
mile a day so i kind of took down i'm
like i just want to walk a mile
and so eventually one day i was able to
get a half mile
that's [ __ ] my therapist because you
keep going you'll get a mile and no
problem
there was one day where i realized i
looked my watch you know
the dominar run and i hit him over a
mile and a half
from i was working on the treadmill in
the morning and when i got home at night
working on again so i took a picture of
it and sent it to my friends and say
look at this [ __ ]
wow so i really i mean i keep that's
trying to readjust my goals
i know there's things that i want to do
i want to get back i i was a big fly
fisherman
so i may never wait in a river again
my buddy clifford oh it's the breath i
gotta call cliff
remember to call cliff cliff come on
i'll call you
i'll get back to you so um i know i was
talking to cliff who's one of the main
fishing buddies
he's like our waiting's overrated just
sitting in the boat with the beer
so um but you kind of need a left hand
to um
work the line after you hook a fish so
these guys send me there's a
an adaptive um rod holder that they sent
me that i'm trying to work out
but um i was able to put there's a line
in lastly
to come home which is all about um
lasseter's recovery from
getting shot and having a stroke where i
say um
and it really mirrored a lot of what i
was going through in my own life
emotionally
and james and steve were great about
just do it so i was able to talk about
you know what if i don't get better how
am i going to teach lily to fish with
one my daughter on the show's name is
also lily
which pissed snore off i think a little
bit rightfully so so uh i said how am i
going to teach my
lily to fly fish with just one hand so
these are things i really am trying to
get to but i'll probably notice
this question nobody really says it's
gonna be this or that and even if they
did i just
i gotta go on i know i'm getting better
there's something called neuroplasticity
which is the brain rewiring itself so
i've seen the effects of it
with the fact that my left arm is
entirely flaccid and now like there's
some movement in it
that's got to be a good feeling i mean
it's it's you know
when in the beginning you're probably
thinking you know i the road just seems
so long you know ahead of you and then
it's probably you hit a point where like
oh well these things are starting to
happen i'm seeing
it that's going to be really exciting to
start to see this kind of go as as
time goes on i mean obviously it's
you're probably a little impatient too
it's like come on [ __ ] arm
you know we're going to impatient yeah
but i know i just i got to i got to put
the work in to get there
yeah so i mean the main thing i have
which like
i've got my sesame here like that wasn't
thank god that my my wit wasn't taken
away i should change what it was like is
it just me
or did it take it funnier after this
trouble
god bless him so it's like i still got
my sense of humor and um
hope i still i have endless sense of
hope like hope is all we have
i'll sending this to a stroke so i
reached out to me on instagram the other
day who's having a hard time
i was like this what you have is hope so
you just gotta keep on that
and it's one thing i mean i'm lucky
enough that i was able to fight
i was not overwhelmed by melancholia if
you want to call it if you want to be
an 1880s um debutante i've got
melancholia
like i wasn't a one but i was able to to
go
i'm going to try and fight this
obviously
there's a lot of people who can't who
don't have that ability to do that
well it's certainly inspiring to hear
someone
you know talk about that and just
hearing you say
this is what you have to do the only way
you're going to get better if you're
going to be
melancholy and depressed and angry all
the time
that's just making it it's so much
harder on yourself obviously but we
don't think like that but
if you have the ability to make the
decision to say hey i'm going to stay
positive i'm going to each
each achievement i have i'm going to be
grateful and that's the direction i'm
going
hearing that from you if someone's out
there or
or other people that it's happened to i
think that is
incredibly encouraging and that can
change someone's mindset because they
could look at your
progress yeah i think progress is really
how you gotta judge i mean everybody's
case is obviously different people have
they have a with a stroke or traumatic
brain injury some kind of when your
brain is affected
everybody's gonna heal differently
depends on how quickly how quickly they
got help
how quickly they would get into therapy
and thank god i have health insurance
that
covers my therapy yeah all right this is
[ __ ] talking
with uh timothy owens and this is uh
from my patrons who get just asked
questions so there's
these this is a rapid fire you could
just go whatever you want but [ __ ]
talking
although they're not really [ __ ] talking
jennifer asked timothy i love both psych
and supernatural which character was
more fun for you carlton or kane um
how do you choose which baby you love
the most easily
uh i would say carlton
that's hilarious other than i would say
carlton
you're right the guy
that got me that guy that was good
dave p it's obvious of the close-knit
family atmosphere on the set of psych
does that spill over in everyday life do
you get together with others
on holidays week weekday ends or a meal
yes
and covered is obviously broken up i
think i spent
the last three christmas eves with
maggie and um james
which is weird thinking this year it's
like oh we're not gonna be able to do
the uh they're not gonna come up for
christmas for our christmas scene party
but uh julie and i were just texting
yesterday about trying to get together
for a distance drink
yeah i'll uh i'll do a voice memo and
i'll sing an 80s song
i go who sings this and james will
immediately get it and delay goes
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care about
this i don't care about these songs and
then every once in a while
he'll get one but uh
let's see chemistry danny sorry he
already asked the chemistry on psych was
just amazing so
that's the question daniel m uh how much
did you enjoy playing almost god and
lucifer
i enjoyed it immensely it was very close
to
to home aubs
like finally they're all that's right
for me god you're almighty
although i did um tom alice's eyes are
so
freaking blue so i was like okay i'm not
right now competing with tom
yeah he seems like a nice guy a lot of
um it's like [ __ ] i'm being rivaled for
my blue eyes damn it
she lots of like crystal blue eye drops
put in did you love hearing that on set
people go gosh your eyes look great
would the makeup artist come over to you
and go
timothy your eyes are just they just pop
you got that admit it sure of course
your eyes are beautiful my gosh they
really pop the angle they have 100 ml
on you and it's right up to your chest
and it's just your eyes are just blue
it was mostly the dp it's like buddy
these
how they doing they good right now we
should they swear that way
oh that one okay tilt down you're just
really exactly where the light's perfect
and i won't move my head
hey this has been incredible and i
already feel like i love you and i want
to hang with you and
uh you drink
uh you know i'm not a big drinker but i
will come and have a drink for sure i'm
not like
i won't drink i just don't smoke i'll
bring you over some uh
welling and i made some wine that uh
stephen amell
he was like you want to have your own
wine and your own labels and you taste
them and
so they sold them on knocking point
wines or whatever and then we got to
make all the stuff and so i still have
tons of bottles because you know i'm not
a big drinker but i'll bring you over a
couple bottles
i got a good porch we could sit there
would some pork sit
i would love that what does your doctor
say about your drinking um
they're kind of like well you always
want to take these i did have a seizure
once after um
a night of a few too many scotches and
maybe one tiny burst but also wasn't
taking my seizure medication so we
realized i am sceptical caesar so i do
have to be able to care about that
here's the one one of the most tragic
things about my stroke
alcohol doesn't affect me the way it
used to this one takes a long time and a
lot of boost for me to get a buzz going
which is really
freaking sad this does stop me from
trying though
wow hey lastly yo go ahead what
no the problem is awake with a lot of
headaches you do
always wake up with headaches not always
but it's like i realize if i'm gonna
have
because i don't necessarily get a little
buzz i'll maybe keep drinking for
watching
some tv my wife and i are binging tv at
night i'll have a few glass of wine then
do i really want more it's like sure one
more because i'm sitting here watching
some tv so i have another i'll have
another drink
then the morning awake i'm like why did
i do that it's not like i'm right
vomiting hangover but just like that's a
little soul i mean so i probably
shouldn't be drinking but um
no i mean my neurologist hasn't said no
don't do that
right it says enjoy it but be smart
you're like but i can't i don't get
drunk so easily so i have to drink more
wine well
just take it easy and then it'd be sort
of an overall whole thing of like well
then maybe don't
it's like why is my belly keep getting
fat well because i had someone try one
hey listen on larry king you said um
someone who inspires you and i thought
that you guys knew each other
but you said selma blair uh i did say
that uh no i don't know selma
we i think we're instagram friends well
i text her after
and i said i sent her that she's like oh
my god that is so i'm you know and she
was so
scared she was so i don't know she was
just she really loved it
and i go well why don't you do an
introduction on you know so i think
she's going to come and do an intro for
this interview and just kind of talk
about her thing for a little while like
you know a few minutes and just
you know because it was like that's
amazing that no but she really does she
does swear i mean i just know her
through her social media posts and
see the struggle she how um gracefully
she's handling
her struggles of again being a single
mother and
that wretched disease she has and
there's there's a gal who's never gonna
throw herself in pity party
yeah she is she is freaking strong and
she's so
honest and forthcoming and just you know
she's an open book that's what i've
always loved about her that she is an
open book she's sort of like
this is who the [ __ ] i am and there's
you know i give her a lot of credit for
that you know
i've been learning how to do that more
especially having the podcast actually
she's
sorry to interrupt um she is really been
an inspiration she's the one because
at the time when i first had the stroke
i was really kind of hiding the effects
of it
because i mean i would i didn't want to
work again i didn't want i didn't want
suddenly
a form of disability intermediate my
possibilities of getting work
and um so like i never i was really
careful to never
really have pictures in the wheelchair
and um i mean now it's kind of totally
different
but julie hill actually we were shooting
the second movie up in vancouver
and we went out to kids speech which is
one of our favorite places having lived
in
vancouver so long my kids were raised on
the beach and there's a there's a
wheelchair mat on the beach
which is a lovely so i was able to walk
out on on this
map and sort of stand there and allison
my wife got a picture of me standing
there
which is this picture that i absolutely
love
and um was like you know you need
pictures of you in the wheelchair
to switch to inspire could go hey look
at this [ __ ]
like he is living his life yeah and it
really it absolutely turned my head
around he was absolutely right
and then i looked at what someone posts
and how just honestly wasn't it and i
realized how much inspired me and
thought well maybe i can
help inspire people as well and to not
be hiding this
well you have you've done an amazing job
of that and uh i think it is helping a
lot of people it's going to help a lot
of people
and you know rob benedict telling his
story on the podcast jamie lynn sigler
telling her story about ms and
you know uh and selma just people
opening up
it just gives people hope and at the end
of the day it's like
you know i always think you know when my
time goes i just want to be able to say
hey i
i helped people i had a good heart i
wanted to do what i could you know
those are the things that i think that
you take with you and i don't think you
think about them very often obviously
when you're younger and you're going
through
hollywood and you're like doing this and
you know you just and then one day kind
of go
well if i could help someone man that is
to me that's life that you know i always
noticed i'm the happiest
and most emotional when i can help
someone you know and especially when
it's altruistic
when it isn't like oh you know uh
it's sort of like you're doing it
because you just you have to do it
because you
feel it it's not because you're like oh
this will be good for me
no no i'll get some press for this
that's not
what it's about i mean i don't you know
what i mean so yeah i know like i never
said when the local news would
air stuff of celebrities you know work
in a soup kitchen over thanksgiving
it's like no you want to keep that on
the down low i mean obviously it's nice
healthy but it's like hey look at me
feeding these
poor people look how awesome i am
but um sorry i just lost my train of
thought before that are you saying um oh
yeah but like you know it's the
difference between people just like sort
of uh
doing it because they just want to do
this not because they're getting pressed
for like
mark messier was a hockey player right
nhl great i've said this before i think
but he said you know the character of
someone when you watch them do things
when the cameras aren't rolling
when you see how good of a person they
are when the cameras aren't rolling and
that just sat with me and it's like
that's exactly what it's about i mean
and the fact that you and i are lucky
enough to have the platforms we do
it's like how do i use this person good
i mean how blessed
am i to have the um the social media
following that i do which
is lovely for my ego but it was like how
can i really do something like
i'm not just checking my neural likes
i'm trying to do something positive in
the world i sort of hit a moment the
other day where it's like the flashback
fridays and throwback thursdays and way
back wednesdays
i found that i was just posting pictures
where i looked awesome
i was like look how cool i look at this
picture i'm going to post it
and then i'll try to come up with
something else like where i would sort
of post stuff for
gratitude tuesday or thankful thursday
this is going here was a mum where i was
so grateful for yeah
i think it's good to mix those up
there's no reason why i'm still posting
pictures where i look awesome
yeah i was just gonna say there's you
know
the other day i posted a an instagram of
me because they had this app on snapchat
i don't even use snapchat i just use it
for the little pictures and the things
you could do to your face and then i
saved them i don't like use snapchat but
it was a bald one and i was lex luthor
again i was like
and i posted it people were like what
the [ __ ] and it looks so cool i was like
holy [ __ ]
this is great but it's you know look we
have a platform so
i think it's it's great to say oh
there's a really good picture of me uh
here's the wonderful things i get to do
and
hey let's uh this is uh let's save lives
here and let's help uh people i think
that all those things are good
you know well something you're awesome
michael we're really incredible that's
what the theme of this whole thing
this podcast was there so what we've
really done i love us yeah
good for us good for us tim michael yeah
you too back at you well listen happy
birthday and
dude this this has been great i really i
loved every minute of it and
i i hope you had fun i had a lovely time
talking i can't wait to get to do this
in person one of these days yeah we're
going to do the wine thing and i
built my tortoise one and by the way
this is so good because so many people
that
they're just gonna i think they're gonna
love this i mean your people love you so
i think this is gonna be really good for
you oh thanks man
all right well i'm gonna keep in touch
and bother you every once in a while so
get used to it say the word man i'll
beat you to it
all right much love to you man thank you
again i'm gonna say this rosie i love
you
i love you too okay i'll see you soon
all right
there you have it guys if you enjoyed
today's show please please subscribe
and on youtube i love it i love you
watching the videos telling me what you
think
i do go back and and respond to a lot of
them
i look at all your responses and uh your
messages and i thank you
from the bottom of my heart and uh
make sure you subscribe on uh on the
audio keep listening
and telling all your friends and uh we
have a great episode coming up next week
it's gonna be a big one
and i've been trying to get this person
for a long time so you're gonna wanna
stay tuned to see who that is i think
you're to really love it you've seen him
in everything
once again the handles ryan uh inside of
you pod on twitter at inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook
youtube.com inside of you that's correct
and go to stageit.com and type in
michael rosenbaum follow me there to
listen to uh you know
we'll let you know when we're playing a
show but remember every last saturday of
the month
um 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific standard time
shows two shows we play covers new songs
left on laurel songs it's a lot of fun
um and a lot of the same people come
back and i boy do i love them and
appreciate their support and we you know
their prizes so we zoom people after the
show and
uh we have a lot a lot of fun doing it i
i i wanted to continue man if i could
just do music for the rest of my life
forget about it
and of course the inside of your store
take 15 off inside use the code inside
15 go to the inside you store tons of
great stuff
uh right now why don't i uh read off the
uh
wonderful patrons that support the show
and
really are the reason a lot of the
reason why i kept this thing going
before westwood one came on
and uh that's been going great and i
hope it continues but it doesn't
continue without your support
so there you go also i can't say
anything but
there was some really cool i had a
really good conversation with someone
uh last week about a potential
work job maybe oh it's just i'm not
gonna say anything all i'm gonna say is
it is something i think that uh
i would like to do i think you should do
it too
well let's not talk about it anymore
okay but uh believe me when i do
announce it if it does happen
which wouldn't be till next year i will
uh i will tell you guys first
but i don't know what it is i mean you
don't know what it is
i sort of maybe know what it is could be
horror
who knows uh here's a shout out to all
the loved
patrons nancy d leah s
tricia sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h lauren g nico p robin asked
jerry w
emily k robert b jason w
do you say w or w i like w george w
w b s stephen j kristen k
amelia o allison l jess j lucas m
raj joshua d we still got to make up a
song
somehow where we just play a song and we
add names to it
i don't know if we play it while we're
just listening so we don't have to keep
recording it
but you know you tell people as part of
the patrons top tiers that you mentioned
you give a shout out
so couldn't a shout out be their names
in a song you could do it uh billy joel
we didn't start the fire style
we didn't start emily essence jp yeah
that'd be tough but we could do it
emily asked cjp samantha m hamzabi
jennifer n jackie p stacy l carly h
jennifer s janelle b
carrie v tabitha 272 not to be confused
with tap of the 273
ashley r kimberly b crystal h mike e
marissa
n jack s slater's back
ramirez beth b santiago m
sarah f chad w lee and p rauschen
rey a maya p megan j matty s tiffany i
kendrick f
ashley e i remember when this list was
really small it's nice
it's huge now it is but [ __ ] it i love
it ashley e
shannon d matt w belinda n lisa j kevin
v
robert s james r chris h snow r a new
should w
h gabby m dave h samantha s
spider-man chase that's correct sheila g
not to be confused with
sheila e yeah that's correct ray h
allison c jacob h tabitha t
misha h deb a tom n
natalie six two two not to be confused
with natalie six two three ali b
henry s katie f daniela v liliana
a those are the patrons
and uh by the way i love each and every
one of you whether you're on this list
or not
and uh in fact i have to send my merch
boxes i have 20 boxes in there that i
have to send out and i have to pack it
up
i think i start i think i probably need
to get more merch
i have so much if you get the same thing
you know i did send you the letter but
i'm gonna
you know the little note but anyway
that's the show uh
ryan thank you as always thank you and
uh
keep up the killer work man killer work
dude uh
bryce i love you buddy thanks for
everything and sun spin
uh come and uh watch us on the stage it
and uh we'll have merch eventually but
the album's going to come out soon and
we play a couple of songs and even when
we play them on stage as good as i think
they sound
they're fun they're just so full we got
my good friend emma fitzpatrick on
vocals and eliot yamin
from american idol he has a great voice
good news songs coming out
um who else uh great musicians
billy uh moran and rob humphries
and just great musicians and i'm really
excited about it and
i love making the left on laurel album
and now this is just the next level
just uh you know i'm trying to expand
and and
keep writing music keep doing what i
love and i think that's important for
all you guys out there
it doesn't matter if you're great at it
or good at it or if you just enjoy it
you just got to do it man just
just do it and that's my cue the
gardeners are here so i'm going to say
goodbye thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
until next time ryan bye